je ne crois pas que le peuple ukrainien
c'est un peuple aussi là le récit non
pas du tout nous faisons un ensemble
tandis que les autorités ukrainiennes
actuelle ce
occupe une position hostile envers la
russie ça c'est évident sinon comment
expliquer pourquoi il propose un projet
de loi à l'art des radars qui concerne
les peuples autochtones où il considère
que le peuple russe n'est pas un peuple
autochtone sur le territoire ukrainien
c'est inconcevable depuis des
millénaires les russes vivent sur le
territoire ukrainien
et cela va amener la situation où
beaucoup de gens vont partir mais ou
partir ils n'ont pas de logement ils
n'ont pas de travail alors il pourrait
peut-être changer de tête ni de
nationalité et cela va amener à la
réduction du nombre de russes c'est on
peut le comparer avec l'effet d'une arme
de destruction massive c'est très
sérieux c'est très grave
on supprime la langue russe dans la vie
quotidienne
et vous savez
partout il ya des nationalistes des gens
têtus même cher en russie en ukraine par
tous et ces gens là sont peut-être
sincère mais ne sont pas intelligents et
leur action est centrée destructive
ils font pression sur l'opposition en
ukraine
messieurs mettez tout par exemple c'est
un nationalistes ukrainiens qui était
écroué et durant la campagne électorale
on prend des décisions qui sont être
inconstitutionnel et illégal mais
personne n'y fait attention à
l'intérieur de ce pays ont fait croire
qu'il n'ya pas de possibilité légale
pour ceux qui veulent construire des
relations normales avec la russie ils
n'ont pas de chance ces gens là
puisqu'ils sont oppressés écroué en
prison massacrés dans la rue à quoi bon
nous rencontrer avec monsieur alinsky 6
et l'ukraine sous l'autorité de céline
ce qui est son contrôle et de
l'extérieur est les aspects clés de la
vie en ukraine sont décidées à
washington à berlin à paris mais bien
sûr je ne renonce pas à ces rencontres
l'air mais je veux comprendre de quoi on
va parler